yes i know this video is a day late but
it's important because today is black
friday which means that our black friday
deal is back that's right get 50
off of dailywire membership with code
dw50 head over to dailywear.com
subscribe or click the link in the
description below so
producer colton is forcing me to cook a
turkey damn it
now before we jump in before i put on an
apron
[Music]
that was unexpected this video is
sponsored by raycon all right let's
get cooking all right here we go i'm
gonna cook this
monstrous thing first let's make sure
it's dead
that's the first step okay now
we're gonna preheat the oven to 425
degrees
telepathically it's done okay rinse the
turkey and pat dry
this thing's large all right
i feel like joey from friends i'm gonna
end up with this thing on my head
here we go turkeys are weird because
they have a strangely humanoid aspect to
them kind of
walking around carrying what was once
alive
it's gruesome and horrifying all right
and i'm supposed to pat this dry
like with a cloth as a hillary clinton
joke guys all right
here we go i don't know what the purpose
of that was
was this thing like dropped in a vat of
urine before and now it's all clean or
what
because i feel like that's insufficient
like should i wash it with soap like
what should i have done here
okay in any case an inspiring inspiring
performance here
create your compound butter by mixing
the room temperature butter freshly
chopped herbs pepper and garlic together
oh good i have to actually chop the
herbs that's great
i see you guys prepped all this for me
but you didn't actually do all the work
so i'm not sure why the hell i'm paying
you
[Music]
is there a cutting board there's a plate
it's not gonna
also why am i using a non-serrated knife
i need to start tonight you can't come
with a non-serious knife we're going to
block is this
better or maybe it won't maybe that was
actually a garbage idea
well here's an idea
i swear to god like what in the world
are these knives
that he's like a salvation army after oj
murdered somebody with them this knife
is
if i had taken my car i believe i
actually have a knife shopper in there
no reason
someone's getting zip recruited in fact
everyone's getting zip recorded
there will be no survivors mixing the
room temperature butter
freshly chopped pepper and garlic this
is the pepper
right here this is
[Music]
not the garlic the f is this
not garlic um like i do understand what
garlic is keep
looking around i know that there is
garlic right there guys i'm aware i'm
aware there's garlic i was just unaware
if you had actually had like powdered
garlic
all right fine thank you
okay you know what
fine let's do this here we go oh yeah
is that like appetizing to everybody
right here that looks good to you
you're sick
margarine does not come off the hands as
easily as one would suspect
what the i can't believe you guys got me
into this
okay this is the old country
it's a lot of pressure watching
everybody watching me peel
a piece of garlic colton just did this
for his own sex satisfaction this isn't
we're not making a dime off this video
[Music]
i'm gonna be smart this time and he's a
fork
start at the cavity work the skin loose
from the bird
use a little olive to loosen the skin
take the compound rudder and roll into
small pieces working them under
the skin as far as possible try to coat
the turkey completely and evenly
[Music]
well
[Applause]
this is all perverse
[Music]
yeah this is awkward
well hi mr turkey
my wife and my mother made turkey and
none of them tried this strategy it's
like oh so you're gonna like completely
disassemble this thing and then you're
gonna
like commit unspeakable act upon it
i feel like this is silence of the lambs
okay now we're gonna take some of this
and put it in there
coating this weird turkey and weird
yep that's what we're doing guys putting
a bunch of weird
in a turkey
okay i feel like this turkey has been
sufficiently abused
this entire video is an hr violation
all right turkey chop the onion into
quarters and the lemon into halves all
right fine
okay rub the inside of the cavity with
more salt
and stuff the onion lemon and leftover
herbs into the cavity do not overstuff
the cavity
well then
it just had a baby
i'm john kerry and i'm reporting for
goodness stuff you filled with onion
this isn't morbid at all
and just stuff out of a dead turkey
great strategy honestly is doused in
coke
really like coca-cola cocaine coca-cola
like what uh it's really sweet when you
when you put it in a pit you put it in a
paper bag when you cook it and retains
the moisture
on the turkey and then the flavoring of
the coke sweetens the turkey
it's really good and sort of bakes off
it creates a syrup i feel like i
overstuffed the turkey but
oh well place turkey in the roasting pan
and into the oven
use some of this to flavor the rest of
the chicken that no one's going to eat
behold this horrific turkey
it the rescue way i should be wearing
oven mitts while we wait
how about we uh say hi to one of our
sponsors
but first give thanks for ray khan's
raycons are fantastic there are many
celebrities who use raycons including me
it may be the only thing that cardi b
and i have
in common other than both being platinum
award winning rappers raycon
offers their wireless earbuds in a range
of fun colors and patterns they are
super comfortable they come with a
variety of fit options
which makes it perfect to fit your ear
the compact carrying case it can charge
your earbuds
four times that's four one more than
three it's four
times on a single charge unlike some of
your other wireless options raycon
earbuds are both stylish and discreet
nodes angling wires no stems
they're great for video chats again
unlike other options they're not one
size fits all they come in a variety of
colors
i love my raycons and you will too
raycon earbuds start about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market they sound just as
amazing
as other top audio brands you know
raycons are great for working from home
working out
listening to music and podcasts for
hours without driving your roommate
significant other children or neighbors
crazy
these raicons are also excellent for
waiting for your turkey to cook
and just chilling out to some of my
favorite music from artists
like megan v with two e's stallion with
two l's
that's how it's spelled right guys again
the everyday 25s that's these slick
babies
these are the best model yet six hours
of playtime seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass more compact design that gives
you
a nice noise isolating fit it also comes
in new fun colors click the link in the
description below or go to
buy recon dot com shapiro yt
below to get 15 off your order
behold the turkey
my god what hastel
wrought
[Music]
okay that is a lot of turkey
i am supposed to baste the turkey in its
own juices
welp isn't awkward at all here we go
yes this is a wet ass turkey
and then i'm supposed to paint this
turkey with this
basting brush like van gogh
of turkeys
[Music]
behold i
have created turkey but since i'm within
a foot of this turkey and talking right
now no one else can eat it because it
covered
so that means it's time to get on my
eating pants
and go to town thank you to you over at
the daily wire
thank you to god almighty above and
thank you to our producers for forcing
me to do this
horrifying video before you go don't
forget to check out our black
friday deal get 50 off of a daily wear
membership with code dw50 at
dailywire.com
subscribe or click the link in the
description this is a serious discount
guys just like this is a serious video
we pretty much never do this i can't
guarantee you we will be able to do it
again next year so
if you've been on the fence about
getting a daily wear membership this
is your chimes that's dailywire.com
subscribe or click the link in the
description to get 50 off your
membership of code
dw50